And everybody, this is Dr. Cutters, I want to give you just a breakdown of differential
diagnosis.
That's what it's called when you're trying to figure out what's wrong with you.
So let's just kind of walk through this, how you need to look at yourself, how you should
demand that a doctor looks at your symptoms.
I know many people are on this course because you're like not getting any answers.
So unfortunately, we're live in a day where practice of medicine has changed dramatically.
And there's nobody to listen to you.
There's nobody to sit down with and I get that.
But this is the way, let's wipe out this course together.
You need to sit down with yourself and look at yourself in the mirror and start asking
yourself these questions.
That's what I'm teaching throughout this whole course is how you should demand either
a doctor looks at you or that you look at yourself to figure this out and to be your
old doctor here.
So normally, you got signs and you got symptoms, meaning that you got objective findings and
you got subjective findings.
I don't feel well, I have headaches, I have a rash, I have swollen joints.
You have to start asking yourself questions, you know, that's what a history is, get a proper
history to find out when did this start, to start it after I went hunting to the woods
and ended up with a possible tick bite, I never did find it.
I started when I was down in Mexico and I got food poisoning.
After that, it just seems like my life has been so changed forever.
It started when I had my third child and it just seems like my whole body changed and
I don't know what happened, I never been able to get things back.
So getting that proper history can be very beneficial to get some possible initial antigens
in an autoimmune disease, initial antigens that sparked issues or brain issues or damage
or inflammation, sources of what could possibly be the cause to all this.
And then doing a proper examination, now that's possible for me to do in a distance for people.
But that's a lost art that's not happening anymore and, you know, doctors are spending, you
know, five minutes with the patient.
There's no proper examination done, there's no neurological examination.
And many times I get to refer you to find a functional neurologist that's going to do
a proper examination.
And then testing, and so many people have come to us and said, you know, I know my doctor
has done these labs, but he's never done any of those labs that you're talking about.
How are you going to find out things unless you do that testing, you can't, you know, how
you going to find out if I have food sensitivities to, you know, cucumbers.
And if I never tested it, you know, there's just no way to know unless you do the test.
And that's how you end up getting a diagnosis, it's supposed to be a normal framework for
a doctor.
You do a history, you do a exam, you do testing, you arrive at a diagnosis in order to formulate
a treatment plan.
Otherwise you just kind of throw in darts at a dart board and that's what many people think
about.
So there's really, you know, from a medical standpoint, five steps to a different, and
then you get a special diagnosis, you're acquiring data from a history, you're identifying
key features and that's from your history, from your exam, from your labs and other tests
that you're doing, and then you're creating a possible representation.
What are there is the possibilities that we're dealing with that you adopt a framework on
how we're going to deal with this, with this case and you apply that to the framework of
developing a treatment plan.
And that's really what we need to do and that's how you need to think of yourself and that's
why you need to educate yourself, need to start asking yourself some questions.
Do I have an active antigen, that means do I have a bacterial infection or a viral infection
that's causing this?
Do I have a flare of a latent viral infection that is very common in the last few years with
COVID?
It's sparked up latent infections, maybe an M-steed bar virus that's been silent for years,
it's now activated and that's the huge piece of my chronic fatigue that I'm dealing with.
Do I have damaged barriers, gut barriers, lung barriers, brain-based barriers?
Your brain barrier is a huge issue for brain inflammation if you haven't watched my video on
the viral inflammation.
I highly recommend that if you're having any brain fog and weird symptoms, do I have food
allergies?
Don't just base that on your history.
You could have, oh I don't have any issues with gluten, I can include no issues, we run
a test and it's through the roof that's definitely causing inflammation in the brain.
So food, missed food allergies are probably the number one thing that we see that are causing
issues and causing inflammation in the brain.
Do I have toxicity?
Not just to heavy metals, but to other things.
Do I have toxicity to poisons in my environment that that is causing issues?
Do I have a mold toxicity, mycotoxins, that is a hidden thing, that's hugely common and
we have seen people that never, ever remember getting a tick bite, ever in their life but
they show positive for live antibodies.
So these are key things to look for and I left out a ton of stuff that you can find
to proper testing.
But then from that you're checking, do I have self antibodies?
That means Dow has the high of these things over time created my immune system to start
developing antibodies against my own tissue.
That's what's called autoimmune diseases and then you have those three different phases
of autoimmune disease.
Maybe it's latent and I don't really have any symptoms for that.
You wouldn't even be in this course if you didn't have any symptoms, so nobody's got that.
So then secondly I'm developing symptoms but I don't really have huge objective findings
being swelling in my joint or loss of thyroid tissue or major changes out of blood test because
of those self antibodies.
Most people are doing this course, you know, in that stage.
Most people in this course are in stage three phase three on autoimmune disease and that's
how we need to develop a treatment plan.
We kind of talked through that already but that's where you got to look at, where's the rest
of the autoimmunity?
There's probably other tissues that you have antibodies to, is it a systemic autoimmunity?
We need to find those things out.
One are the dietary triggers because if you have any antibodies to other things and you keep
sparking a reaction, you are going to cause your problem just to continue to spiral downwards
and I don't care how many supplements you take, you're not going to be able to help yourself.
So you have to find that out.
One are the lifestyle triggers.
Are you getting it off sleep?
Are you dealing with emotional issues?
Are you dealing with work type issues?
Are you getting exercise?
Are you over exercising?
What are the chemical triggers?
Are there pollutants that fire a reaction?
It's likely because you have some sort of chemical toxicity.
Also, we need to uncover that.
Are there antigenic triggers, meaning from positive, like I mentioned, latent Epistene
bar or some latent chlamydia or something like that, that keeps fire at a reaction?
Are there immune barrier issues?
Almost everybody in this course has an immune barrier issue and then what are, what are
the degrees of this immune tolerance?
This is how we really have to start developing our treatment program because sometimes you
just can't do all of this at one time and it's not in your best interest too.
So where do we break the stout and start developing a treatment plan to start healing?
And if I can do one thing to drill into your head, it is a long-term process.
This is a lifestyle process.
You're never going to be able to make yourself and everybody's go away.
You have to just learn how to best manage this and that's going to be different for everybody.
Two people with rheumatoid arthritis are going to have a totally different management
style and that's just the way it is.
Everybody is unique and different.
That's what this whole course is for.
So stay with it.
Remember, I'm praying for you, hang in there, don't give up.